this weekend um I spent a lot of time
thinking about what true femininity is
and I thought about how you have these
women that sell femininity courses um
and they typically have on a lot of
makeup and maybe they sell courses on
makeup um getting your nails done and
looking elegant and really there's
nothing wrong with that image matters
image is important but a lot of times
I'll meet these women and there's not an
ounce of femininity in their body and I
was trying to understand like why are
these women not feminine I can see that
they're not feminine but I can't exactly
explain to you why and I thought about
how one of the most feminine women I
have ever met in my life um really she
didn't have the latest fashion trends
and she was overweight she wasn't what
these women sell and I thought to myself
what makes her
selfless and the conclusion I came to
was when you think about our great
grandmothers and our grandmothers they
they didn't care about the latest
fashion Trends they didn't care about
being all polished and proper what was
most important to them was the men in
their lives true and this is what I
tweeted true femininity is actually
women serving men it has nothing to do
with clothes fashion or having your
nails done if you go get your nails done
they are serving you therefore it is not
feminine and my thought process was is
all of these girls that are really into
fashion typically live very self selfish
lives and the things they do are
typically for them and therefore it
makes them unfeminine so J responded to
this and he said femininity doesn't
expand it enhances masculinity so then I
had another
tweet this made some people mad I said I
heard married wives and mothers are
getting Botox why he already married you
what more do you need spend that money
on your children and I thought about the
women that invest a lot into their looks
again it's not feminine it's one thing
if you are investing into your looks for
the man in your life but men have
overwhelmingly said we do not want this
we do not want Botox we do not want fake
hair extensions we do not want a ton of
makeup no no no we do not want this and
it really just leads me to the
conclusion that really most of these
wives that are spending all of this
money on their appearance parents are
doing it for the external validation
rather than their husband's validation
therefore making it not feminine women
that are getting work done if you pulled
their husbands what percent of them
would say yes I am so happy my wife is
putting in injections into her face the
mother of my children yes I am so happy
that the mother of my children is
tattooing eyeliner yes I am so excited
that the mother of my children spends
two hours every day on her makeup do men
really want this and the common argument
that I hear is yes men want it but they
don't know that they want it and what
that tells me is I get more attention
from men when I do these things and my
question is if you're married why do you
need attention and validation from the
outside world why is your husband's
opinion not the most important important
and really if you want to belong to a
guy the question is what does he like
when I wear it what does he want me to
do and most men look at all of this
stuff as an expense and and I expanded
on this in my tweet I said the wives and
mothers that are wasting all of this
money on Botox nails fashion are telling
on themselves it shows their priority
themselves their looks attention from
men and not what ding ding ding their
family and we have to talk about ideals
on this show when we talk to women that
are actually the ideals that really are
the most selfless feminine women that
you have met are they typically women
that are worried about the latest
fashion trends they are typically
worried about their children and
typically they don't want to spend money
on themselves they want to spend money
on the children that is a true feminine
women a woman that puts the family above
herself and what we have now is a bunch
of Kim Kardashian wives that are playing
pretend it's me me me me me my career
what I want and it doesn't matter what
my husband wants and the kids want and
we saw this when Kim Kardashian and
Kanye were married and Kanye repeatedly
told Kim that he didn't want her wearing
certain types of outfits and her
response is that well I was like this
when you married me and while that is a
valid point my question is are we all
going to be exactly the same all through
marriage and isn't it your job as a wife
to submit to your husband's Authority
even when he changes directions
and again it shows the problem with the
modern wives it's a lack of control they
need to be in control of everything
everything needs to be the same from the
day we get married till the day we die
otherwise I have been deceived now I got
a response from free Ashley she says
women need to work on their appearance
through marriage so their husbands
remain attracted to them physically also
women spend too much money worrying
about their appearance after they are
married pick one you can't have both yes
I can and I'm going to tell you how I
can when I say worry about your
appearance focusing on Fitness and being
healthy will actually put you in the top
25% of women because 70% of women are
overweight in the United States so you
actually can have both you can focus on
your appearance wanting to look good for
your husband without spending hundreds
of dollars a month on face creams
moisturizers heavy makeup and Botox we
don't need this and typically women that
are heavily invested in their looks they
not happy with the option they have they
simply want a better one I I asked my
producers to give me an example of a
woman in the media that has done a ton
of work over time do you see on the left
how she almost has this like feminine
essence of her and it's interesting
because even when women age and they get
older but they don't get work done
there's something more pure about the
way they look there's something more
feminine and then on the right it's
almost like an older woman trying to
cosplay a younger woman and we can all
see it maybe it's more visually
attractive slightly but there's a
difference between attraction and beauty
and there's something about a woman that
has gotten very little work done that
just ages I I don't want to say better
but more gracefully over time and you
you start to see these women that are
too invested in their looks and I think
a lot of women have been lied to and
they end up at 50 just looking kind of
nutty looking kind of crazy because
eventually both Talk starts to fade and
then and then you know when you think
about it how much money did you spend on
yourself that you could have really
spent on your family so um Monica
Crowley a prominent conservative
political commentator and talk show host
has been a fixure in the American Media
for decades with a career that spans on
radio television and various political
roles she's gained recognition for her
sharp intellect and articulate
communication however over the years the
topic of Monica Crowley's appearance has
become a subject of specul ation leading
to rumors of plastic surgery I think
it's pretty obvious this chick has said
plastic surgery um but it's almost like
it they switch their faces switch from
beauty to I don't even know what to call
it like fake sexy and and it's sad
because it's like God gives us this
natural beauty and we we continue to
manipulate what God has given us I would
argue this is a Telltale sign of a lack
of femininity most women that have had
heavy work done that are Ultra focused
on their appearance are not overly
feminine because they are focused on
themselves and not their husbands in
general